the end game of kang is to establish the
fantastic four
and doom in a vast endless war for the
future of the marvel
multiverse instead of leading up to an
avengers movie it's all leading up to a
young avengers movie
here is our version of apocalypse here's
how we're going to
get the x-men involved
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm marina
mastros i'm hosting for today
and uh of course eric voss hi everybody
and leo garcia
glad to be back and back again as always
is our good buddy jovan here he is
that's right the self-proclaimed bad boy
theories
is here you know it's real because
i didn't know we were cutting wrestling
promos that's what the show has become
leo i'm sorry we couldn't control it
it's just
you missed it but that is what it is now
uh this is rogue theory uh the podcast
that brings you the wildest nerdy hot
takes on the topics you
can't stop arguing about okay so guys
the big news right now is that lovecraft
country actor jonathan majors has been
cast in the upcoming ant-man 3
so sources say he'll be playing the
villain kang the conqueror
the time traveling mastermind in the
avengers and the fantastic four and the
marvel comics
um if kang is being planned as the
antagonist for a whole wave of stories
what future mcu title is marvel using
kang to build
toward guys that is the question uh well
i have an
idea on this um you might have seen
tuesday's video how i went into how kang
could be introduced in the first and
loki on disney plus
and then you know when ant-man 3 poses
kind of quantum realm threat it seems
like that quantum realm city is now
being established as the
doma style of uh of kang the conqueror
but uh i really do think the end game of
kang
is to establish the fantastic four and
doom in a
vast endless war for the future of the
marvel
multiverse yeah i think there's gonna be
some kind of post-credits scene at the
ant-man three
you know at the end of the titles off
and say like so and so we'll return
in and i think we're going to see kang
will return in
marvel's the fantastic four and
everyone's minds are going to be blown
i think this is all building towards
it's got to be building toward an mcu
fantastic horror movie we know that's
probably direction they're going
everyone's thinking they're going to do
fantastic four before they do
x-men i could see it going the other way
too this is just the way i kind of hope
it goes
so i think after ant-man and the other
avengers
essentially hijacked what we now know to
be kang's time vortexes in the quantum
realm during the whole avengers indian
time heist
uh i think kang now wants to rebuild his
timeline empire with a series of
paradoxes
that all aimed towards in in this other
video i made
stealing the original pin particle back
in the 1960s
and i think that battle is going to
cause the fantastic four in doom from
the 60s
to get sucked into the quantum realm
maybe spend too much time in there
because i think the mcu is going to
establish the quantum realm
and the negative zone as one and the
same because
they're essentially the same thing yeah
yeah the way the issue is done
the quantum realm is essentially what
the negative zone is right they
establish another thing that is exactly
like that they're gonna be like why
didn't you just make those
hard to do yeah um so i think all these
characters are gonna get irradiated in
the quantum realm the way janet van dyne
did they're gonna get powers but the
fantastic four are gonna get out of
there
but doom's going to stick around in the
quantum realm because i think doom is
going to want to use
the time travel down there to save his
mother in latvia
uh and i think the fantastic four is
going to be like hey maybe we don't
meddle too much with this stuff
sorry vic we're going our own direction
right that's gonna piss off doom he's
gonna feel betrayed he's gonna be like
why wouldn't we do why wouldn't we use
this opportunity to fix
everything that's wrong in the world
yeah um so i think what's gonna end up
happening
doom might make a deal with kang and
he's gonna
decide to try to help kang ruin the
marvel heroes
so that the future is the apocalyptic
vision that kang wants
basically we're gonna see a war between
two sides in the marvel multiverse
you're gonna have the heroes who want to
just keep things
peace and civil not too chaotic not
metal too much with like the multiverse
or time travel
and then you're gonna see the bad guys
who want that chaos
who need that chaos need the future to
look bleak because it justifies their
own existence
and that's where i think the battle
lines are going to be drawn going
forward we need it
we need the future to be to be bad we
need to mess with the timelines
let's make it dark let's make it dark
we're going gonna drag everybody else
down with us and that's what villains do
uh that sounds great
um eric there's also connection there
with the
kang's leg like legacy right because he
is
supposedly uh a descendant of reed
richards
yeah absolutely yeah i think that's
going to be tied in on the other side of
it
uh the whole uh connection maybe that
won't even be revealed
yet and that could be revealed like at
the end of the fantastic four movie
because yeah it's all connected there
too how would that be like
an inverse empire strikes back where
it's like uh
i am your grand great grand son
yeah but it's just real long because
it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah great
great great
great great great great yeah great great
great
great theater like great great
great great great
grandson there's a longer space between
each grape yeah
everyone in the theater's just skeletons
yeah i really wanted the rest of this
particular video
just to be him saying great
never know never know just wait till it
comes around to my turn to talk
my favorite we're all skeletons um
great eric that's great it makes a lot
of sense to me um and it sets up
uh like potential conflicts in the
future for uh
that have the potential for longevity
right because we're like oh where are we
gonna go we just had this
infinity war which was over the course
of multiple movies and was its own kind
of like adventure and it was really
um long and lots of build up toward it
and if they want to have something else
like that again
they'll need to set up something from
multiple films that we're
able to get invested in and i think that
makes total sense
um so eric you get two rogies and and uh
the form
that the rogueis come in on my side are
um
candy and i and i eat it oh okay
[Laughter]
thank you marina so that was i was like
searching
i'm searching my desk for like what i
can use as rogies and i'm like uh
rechargeable double a batteries
yep yep eric's was a reese's pieces a
reese's pieces that looks like a cup
are you here i mean sorry yeah the cup
sorry um
yeah it's time to shine and i don't mind
if i do skis
let me tell you what i am thinking now i
hated that irrigated
i know where he's going to
oh man uh we all want to run but at
first we need to learn how to walk and
we didn't have
thanos introduced at the beginning of
iron man 1
no in our first phase of marvel movies
we actually got
loki and he turned out to be a character
that was just always popping up
throughout all the movies
and i think that's what we're really
seeing here with with kang
and i think over time we shall see king
actually become
king of the conqueror maybe we'll see
him in ancient egypt a little bit maybe
we'll get some time
uh fights in the future when he actually
takes over
uh the future and becomes king the
conqueror uh but more importantly
because
this introduction could be happening in
an ant-man 3 or
ant-man and the wasp ii or ant-man and
the wasp and kang which i'm sure will be
what it officially is called uh we are
now seeing
in this movie where cassie lang is now
older we know
that she will uh has the possibility to
become part of the young avengers and
then we've got a hawkeye series that'll
be coming out before this so that's
where we're gonna get kate bishop
um and of course by the time this movie
actually happens we should be done with
all the multiverse
of madness with doctor strange where
maybe we should have a new
normal so that lets us come back to kind
of time travel
so i think that yes we will get a a
little tease at the end of loki much
like uh
eric said where yes kane will probably
show up there and that's like the moment
where we see him turn around his chair
is like oh it's gang
and then from there we're going to just
see him popping up in a bunch of
different movies
and eventually instead of leading up to
an avengers movie it's all leading up to
a young avengers movie where we see all
these other characters from different
places
after the multiverse of madness we're
going to have speed and magic then kind
of
uh join the fray and speaking of those
two i think there will be some
some uh time travel in hijinks where
cassie and kate bishop have to jump
towards the future to fight and find
kane the conqueror but to find out that
magic and speed are
already there fighting them and uh you
know miss marvel
shows up in the mix in some way as well
and i i think
that even if we got this as a series it
might be more like
oh uh legends of tomorrow where they're
chasing one bad guy throughout time so
we see all that
i don't know i think that's fun and then
it also gives marvel their chance to
cameo some of their other future
characters
maybe even uh uh bishop
i think uh from x-men was the
time-traveling character yeah
so i think that just gives us the chance
to throw in some more of the uh the
x-men in there as well
but i think that they're gonna have a
lot of focus on the young avengers
that's great very smart actually yeah i
can say that too i would much prefer a
young avengers series to a young
avengers movie
i i think yeah in general mini series
over films
you can take your time with the story
there's less pressure to get it all done
in two hours
and like either people love it or hate
it over the course of a series people
tend to be more forgiving to a mini
series yeah
plus that gives us a chance to kind of
just jump in and incorporate a bunch of
different time periods versus like you
know in one movie being like all right
we're in the 60s okay great now we're in
like
1800s and it just gets a little muddled
yeah
german that's great uh you also get two
rogies in the form of me eating
more reese's i hope i get tasted
it's a great episode yeah road theory
for marina
yeah it's almost like she's structured
this all just to benefit her
yeah yeah no matter who wins i win
you're just gonna be a huge like a monty
python guy at the end
um one more mint
i feel like we're we have like voodoo
doll like taste buds right now i too can
taste the chocolate and it's delightful
you're having a stroke i will pass out
i completely agree with jovan's uh
assumptions about
kang leading to uh young events thank
you thank you i think that would be
amazing for a multitude of reasons uh
least of them being that
a member of the actual young avengers is
the iron lad
which is like a different version of
gang which is the cutest
has to be the cutest hero name
he's just an iron lad
we all immediately go to our very
non-stereotypical irish voices when we
say that
so i'll go in a different direction
although german kind of spoke to it
there is a version that i think one of
kang's first time travel
he goes all the way back to ancient
egypt searching for an
heir apparent uh to himself and he comes
upon
apocalypse unfortunately i think because
apocalypse was so
recently the big bad in a
okay x-men movie
an x-men movie it was an x-men movie
existed so unless they are trying to
very quickly turn around and retcon like
hey forget that stuff
here is our version of apocalypse here
is our version
here's how we're going to get the x-men
involved i don't really see that
happening
but it would be fun for them to put
their stamp immediately on
that part of the universe and be like
forget about
those fox movies focus on these
hey you know even if it's just like a
little throwaway easter egg in eternals
right which is going back to ancient
times if you see like some kind of
hieroglyphics of like
of kang with uh with apocalypse like
that could be enough for us to do a
couple of videos about the
battle of the century king versus
apocalypse and it's the reason king has
to leave the past
yeah i mean it's a 2016 feels like uh
40 years ago so
well since i gave jovan to leo you also
get two because you agree with them so
so there you go oh fantastic i found a
loophole in romans
i'm out of candy uh and i don't want to
go get more because
because it's in the other room and i'm
not gonna do that but um you get
to see the cute garden labels that i
made
oh wait yeah
um their little little name plates for
my little garden stuff so
so there you go you get two of those um
sweet
and you and they are edible yeah which
i'm not going to do right now but they
are for sure
i should say sweet bell peppers there
you go there you go
uh but before we continue with this
episode i actually want to thank some
people helped to make it starting with
our friends at draftkings so
football is back and teams were back out
on the gridiron over the weekend it was
just weak one people there's no better
place to get in on all the action
than with giraffe kings the leader in
one day fantasy sports
to add this week's excitement draftkings
has millions of bucks and
total prizes up for grabs if you haven't
tried draftkings yet
head on over to the app store right now
because you do not
want to miss this draft your lineup
right now feel
the sweat like never before every run
every pass
and every catch means more with
draftkings it's simple
just pick your lineup stay under the
salary cap and see how your team stacks
up against the competition
nothing adds to the excitement of
watching the game quite like having a
shot at millions of dollars in prizes
jeff draftking has paid out billions of
dollars to winners
since 2012 so they know a thing or two
about cold hard cash
download the draftkings app right now
and use the code rogue
for a limited time new users can get a
free shot at millions of dollars in
prizes this week don't miss out on the
week two action
enter code rogue to get a free shot of
millions of dollars in prizes with your
first deposit that's code rogue only at
draftkings
make it rain minimum five dollar deposit
required eligibility restrictions apply
see draftkings.com for details we're
also going to thank our friends at
hydrant for sponsoring this episode
we all know that we should drink more
water especially if our state is on fire
uh but by the time you feel thirsty it's
too late your home is burning around you
and your lungs are filled with wildfire
smoke
because of forest management no because
of climate change
uh you're already dehydrated you can't
focus you feel tired well
something that will help you feel
refreshed and hydrated is our friends at
hydrant they've created
this refreshing electrolyte powder that
you just mix into water to hydrate you
quickly
and keep you going longer every rapid
hydration mix has the four essential
electrolytes that your body needs and it
packs a bunch
to help your body hydrate fast and stay
that way hydrant
is backed by research my friends the
formula was developed by an
oxford scientist why am i making fun of
that
they know what they're doing um it's
apparently loved by pro athletes has
thousands of five star reviews
it's made with a real fruit juice powder
and comes in a variety of delicious
flavors including
new summer friendly iced tea lemonade
and fruit punch
now the iced tea lemonade is really nice
one considering these hot
summer days uh or currently on fire uh
fall days leaving you refreshed and
feeling great
thanks hydra hydrate is backed by a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
it send it back for a full refund but i
have a feeling you're really gonna love
it
we've got a special deal for our
listeners to save 25
off your first order just go to drink
hydrant.com rockstars or
enter our promo code of rockstars at
checkout that's d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n-t
dot com slash rockstars and enter promo
code rockstars for 25
off your first order drink hydrate.com
rockstar's initial promo code rockstars
to save 25
off and we thank them for sponsoring
rogue theory and uh hey the holiday
season's right around the corner and
this year we know that people will be
buying more stuff online than ever
before
if you're an ecommerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of a
record-breaking online shopping
season maybe not but you can be ready
with shipstation we also want to thank
shipstation for sponsoring us
shipstation helps online sellers of any
size get orders out quickly save money
on shipping and keep customers happy
they'll get you the shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies
not anymore it's for everybody it is the
fastest the easiest and the most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just
a few clicks and you will be managing
your order and getting your product to
happy customers
shipstation works with all the major
carriers and their interface brings your
products together
whether you're selling them on etsy on
amazon or on your own website
shipstation is the number one choice of
online sellers you'll ship more and less
time with the best rates available
and right now rogue theory listeners can
try shipstation for free for 60 days
when you use
offer code rogue make sure your business
is ready to meet the demands of a
massive online shopping season get
started today
at shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in
rogue r-o-g-u-e that shipstation.com
and then enter code rogue
shipstation.com make
ship happen guys every week we play a
game of rogue theory with our patrons on
the new rockstars
discord channel so this week we have
patrons pitch theories about the ongoing
season two of
the boys which we are covering with our
boys underground show every weekend with
yours truly
and eric and tommy when he's not um
breaking into houses
um and we had we asked our patrons to
pitch who they think
killed a certain cia operative and why
which we also discussed but we want to
know what you guys think
um and we had some really fun theories
this week so dr
zoidberg had an interesting take on
frenchie mlgx pitched suado
and won the audience vote and also
tommy's heart
uh but our winner was russell mc with
their theory that
incorporated lamplighter and a
previously
unseen group of imprisoned soups so yeah
really cool yeah hey good job russell
you it looks like you were going through
some of the trailers the way we were
going back through them
uh with like the leftover footage that
hasn't shown up in season two yet it
seems like that
seems to be the direction they're going
maybe we'll see this episode or this
weekend's episode and it makes
um eric feel bad feel better about
himself and how he spends his time
so like someone else is going through
that footage as well yeah
validation um
and don't forget you guys can play
discord rogue 32 by becoming a patron of
new rockstars and joining our
discord uh great guys so
our second topic um this week is
very uplifting it's gonna make us feel
good and it's how will four die
uh last week thor actor chris hemsworth
did an interview with a polish magazine
where he said that the upcoming thor
love and thunder
will not be his last outgoing uh will
not be his last outing as
the god of thunder his fellow big three
in the avengers iron man and captain
america
got nice endings to their arcs in end
game
and you know broke all of our hearts in
the process
uh assuming a fifth thor movie could be
his swan song guys how should thor's
mcu story end i'm gonna say
leo go first uh i'm glad i'm going first
because
i'm going to give you the most rogue
theory and i
i don't think they're going to do the
iron man sacrifice death
um i don't see them doing something
with a nice bow on on top like the
captain america farewell
um i don't even know if thor
as a bean can be killed in the mcu we
don't really
know that uh at least he might just go
on living in some weird ass guardian
didn't die getting blasted by a star so
yeah
um but i think what i enjoy most about
chris hemsworth thor
is sort of this uh comedic value that he
brings to
especially since ragnarok where he
comments
on the things that are not uh of space
magic
you know and i think like i think a lot
of that's that's seen an end game when
hawkeye's very they're all upset about
uh black widow's death
and he's like you're a very earthly
being we're talking about space magic
here
and then like that that kind of my idea
for what thor
what happens after thor five would be
that he still exists in the mcu
but only pops up in bits to sort of
comment on whatever new version of
avengers exists
i'm cast him sort of like as a glenn
beck sort of like
antagonist uh who who's sort of like
it's very cute that you think you're the
avengers i was in the real avengers
you know he's just cranky he's just
cranky
yeah yeah make a blackboard and drawing
the still worlds tree on he's like this
is connected to midgard
exactly he's wearing a hat that says
make avengers great again
you know
i mean these these are the things that i
would like i don't actually want to see
that but i think
that is funny that is pretty funny i do
like it even popping up and sort of
commenting on whatever is going on in
the mcu from time to time
and sort of saying that like he was part
of the the greatest generation
how cute it is that they're still that
they oh we we
saved the universe guys yeah we say the
universe relax
yeah that's so cute um i i know
that you said you weren't gonna get any
but are get any brogies
but um you said stuff that was funny and
dumb
and that always carries with me uh
so you also get you get two for that
just as good as anybody else's
legitimate theory so far
sweet and when i'm hosting there are no
rules
funny and dumb put it on my headstone
oh man um okay joven
uh yes um my idea
here my theory if you will since that is
how the show works
is that uh you know i don't think
that we're going to see marvel repeat
itself too many times with like
sacrificial deaths or you know
as you put uh like like nice little bows
on top uh
i think that what we're gonna see here
is is there's a different times in the
comics where thor just can't
be bothered with the problems of
mortals because he's a god and i think
that is something that they should
really play with because that dynamic is
so interesting
um and and we've seen this big
redemption arc
to the point now where thor's
technically found out like he's still
worthy
he's still he's redeemed himself once
and and then continued to stay worthy
and i think we're going to follow this
story arc of him just being
redeemed to the point where he then can
actually
lead the newars new asgardians and
become their
king now we've got the king thor in the
comics i think it will be kind of a spin
on that
now as i said he's he's redeeming
himself and at the end of end game he's
like no no it's not my time to leave
because he's not
ready yet i think there will be a time
that he does go to retire and he's like
i will lead my
people i'll take it from here valkyrie i
will
lead them i shall become king thor and
you know then just kind of live it up
as a norse god because you know
if given the chance i want to live as a
norse guy
who wouldn't do that blankets they have
it's got to be
so cozy during the winter yeah nice and
also i like that because um we you
should write we've seen him
sort of like really change over time
because at first he was kind of just a
dick
and like was really sarcastic about
everything and was like
your concerns don't matter to me like
why are you even talking to me just fill
up my beer and then
get me another or whatever yeah um and
it would
bring it back around to be like okay
he's gonna start taking responsibility
for everything again because he did he
just kind of like
bounced and i know everybody made fun of
fat thor but like
you know he did definitely take a break
from being a leader for for a while
it's called character development and
he's got the most of it
he has changed yeah a lot
um i also would like i think he's his
facial hair has changed and his like
hair has changed over the
over a bunch of different movies and i
think it's time for him to have your
look jovan
would you just go full stash a full
stash and like
just double here because we haven't seen
that from him yet and that that would
alone would be worth it to me
well but then if he does that then i
have my look that then gets compared to
chris hemsworth look and i cannot
survive with that comparison none of us
can none of us can
um great you get a rogue as well and it
comes in the form of
pumpkins pumpkins just in time for that
sweet spice to go into my coffee yeah
there you go
i love the idea that no one can be
compared to chris hemsworth not even his
brothers
yeah exactly yeah there's more than one
yeah
oh poor luke
uh eric bring it home for us uh
i love both of those theories i want to
see a version of that like let's make
thor
the most like recurring character and
then all these incarnations can exist at
some point
um i think it looks like thor fourth or
eleven thunder is doing this whole
uh jason aaron mighty thor thing with
jane foster you know and she's gonna
pick up the hammer
i think they are gonna adapt this thing
like they're bringing back natalie
portman but i think just for one movie
you know i think they're gonna do the
cancer arc i think she's gonna power up
but then it resets her chemo and i think
at the end she's gonna like decide
and i'm good uh i think they're bringing
in christian bayless gore the god
butcher
and i think he might lose the battle but
he's gonna get under his skin and after
losing jane foster you're gonna see
maybe in a fifth movie someone is gonna
remind thor of that we're gonna get the
the gore was right moment you know the
in the comics nick fury whispers in his
ear and thor like drops at him and
retires but they're gonna do it after
this
um and then but it might be like hella
like or it might be loki or it might be
one of those people
i don't know if it'll be nick fury who
says it uh but then i think it's gonna
end with like thor dropping the hammer
whatever version of the weapon he has
and beta ray bill's going to pick it up
and he's going to take over after that
that's what i want to see man you want
to win me over you throw in some beta
get him in there um but i think it's
going to end with like
thor after he retires just walking out
into the ocean
into the jaws of the giant gormangander
snake
you know that they keep teasing he might
fight because i think he's gonna be like
the mcu's captain jack sparrow
they did call him a pirate uh right
didn't they say he was a pirate am in my
head
yeah and he's just going to walk into
like how captain jack went into the
kraken
he's going to walk right into the jorman
gander and then go into this like weird
afterlife space and get like resurrect
and become glenn beck
or king or whatever yeah it's very like
elizabethan
like i just want this is it let me walk
in let me walk into the ocean with
stones in my
in my coats pockets
[Laughter]
yeah any ending that reminds me of the
ending of frankenstein
um is is good where you just like wander
off
into the wilderness or on an ice sheet
there's an episode of i may destroy you
that ends that way and i was like
did she drown oh my god i know right
yeah
because she's like wearing her full coat
and i was like oh girl no
it's such a good show i love it it's so
good um eric you get two rogues for that
and that is that you get just a zucchini
zucchini
um so it's very close eric has four
leo has four jovan has three but don't
worry it's anybody's game because right
now we're gonna do
rogue questions baby so um
yep here we go here we go [ __ ]
uh buckle up [ __ ] the intensity
bring it yeah i know i also like knocked
my camera a little bit hang on
okay that's how you know you really
brought it i know i know
um all right guys here we go wrote
questions get yourselves ready
um okay number one in hopes of spurring
space
capitalism nasa is offering 15 to 20
thousand dollars
to anyone who can harvest moon rocks
so what's your totally legitimate and
not at all silly pitch
for becoming the first moon rock farmer
i think if you're gonna do it you need a
really good
structure and a strong business plan so
what i'm
saying is if you pay me and then i will
be able to get some moon rocks but then
you
both then you'll get two other people to
pay you yeah
you can buy some moon rocks and then
once we have them on board
they'll get i'm less people yeah yeah
i'm going to get the moon rocks from the
moon and bring them to everyone else
uh pyramid schemes are great so you get
to
i'm sorry this is just a layered
yeah it's different it's a square plan
that's not a pyramid scheme
very square i i mean i'm just gonna keep
it simple i coming from florida i know
the kind of people who live
outside cape canaveral and i just
imagine one of them wandering in there
and be like hey
listen mr nasa i'm just going to tell
you one thing
i'm not going to put those moon rocks up
my butt
and just drop the mic ball's in your
court
i'll tell you what's not going to happen
is those rocks going up my butt
i feel like the rocks are going up your
butt no i said not going up my butt
that's the one place i said they weren't
go go
you have my word uh great you got a
roggy leo what
what do you say uh i sort of reject the
premise of this question
but oh that's the business wow that's
the first that's the new exercise
yeah that's great if i'm forced it
forced to answer it
uh that's so funny well all i would say
is what i think would make me a great
moon rock farmer is that i'm a huge fan
of the genre of music post
rock and so i would play but for my
for my moon rocks if i were growing them
on the moon because i assume they grow
um like any sort of what farmers do
i would uh play for them mogwai cigar
ross
explosions in the sky and i think i
would grow the best
moon rocks based on the music i played
for them
leo you get two rogues for rejecting the
premise uh here we go
question number two uh chris evans
accidentally
shared an intimate photo last week um if
his
butt is oh my god if his butt is
america's ass
what's a good nickname for captain
america's dick
this is a great question and you all
have to answer it
i mean i'll say i think what is the
obvious one uh
i mean if it's america's ass it's got to
be captain's [ __ ] right
the alliteration yeah that's good that's
good
but here's what i'll really say and this
is really for producer zach behind the
scenes
um we really want to know uh
what captain's [ __ ] produces i think
that's a super soldier semen
[Music]
oh my god it's true that's right
that's all they need and they get a
bunch of cat new capped americans that's
all you need
there you go uh you get a roger great
next
uh i'm i'm gonna go uh in a humbler
direction um i'm gonna go with yes he
has america's ass
but on the other side of it really is
just uh
private rogers privates that's good it's
nice
it's great yeah classic alliterative
yeah very cle yes very classy that's
right and it keeps it sort of in the
military family
yeah that's right yeah yeah right you
get a rookie for being classy eric
i want you to just imagine uh chris
evans delivering this line during
adventures in game but
bucky is alive he's saying [ __ ]
that was great um eric you were gonna
get five rogies for that but you did an
impression with your face so you get
zero
okay fair podcast listeners just use
your imaginations
use them guys last question here's where
you get your points in
um paramount is making an animated
horror movie based on an image comic
series called stray dogs that's being
called silence of the lambs meets lady
and the [ __ ] that is so
sad it is so sad it's just a lot of
animal
cruelty sounds like um what would a dog
that could speak like hannibal lecter
say okay so this is a dog this is just a
murderous
dog right like it's just a dog or
or it's a very nice and happy dog but
who
but who says things in a creepy way like
hannibal lecter
okay any interpretation thereof um i
love the sounds of the lambs i
watch it all me too yeah it's so i'm
gonna
not do one of the more famous hannibal
lecter quotes but you know one that
you might know uh so um
memory agent starling is what i have
instead of a
squirrel yeah there you go
and then you just stab the squirrel and
eat it
uh great guys
uh i'll do another off the beaten path
hannibal quote
uh the the tragedy is not to die
but to not be called a good boy
great amazing amazing uh i'm just gonna
go with the the sadistic
dog route here and i think this dog
would uh kind of uh maybe have a
mustache of his own and
just look and it's on his eyes and all
right karen
i see here that you've gone ahead and
put the kibble in the bowl
does this look like it's a delectable
meal no never again shall you
fool me with this breaded food i see you
with different
ideas of consumption every single day
and here we are
was that so we shall not have this dry
food anymore but meat cooked
rare every single day that was the
moment
you have just you have to say it puts
the it puts
the kibble in the basket or whatever
right it puts the kibble in the ball
stealing buffalo bills yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you were all over the map on this one
great uh
i will tell you the final scores because
i have them tabulated on my official
uh candy cane tabulated yep
um eric you had five joven you had six
leo you had seven
[Music]
there you go do i get to tweet as you
again
oh my god well what's your wish
i don't have a wish no wishes i just
like that one time i got to tweet as you
and i
had an awful uh i left the word out
omitted a word
to wish her freedom yeah nice you can do
it again
um but you have to text it to me because
you can't like i can't i'm not there to
have give you my phone
so you can tell me what you want to say
and then i'll tweet it and then be like
this is what leo made me tweet
i tried to say slime or [ __ ] yeah
and it auto-corrected
and everyone was like marina what is
wrong with you
and i was like it's gonna make sense and
that was back when like we recorded a
week before and so like
i had to wait a week of everybody on
twitter being like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with marina
yeah what is eric's dying forgot about
that
yeah it was really bad so you get to do
it again leo so start thinking about
what you want to
start thinking about yeah um okay so
that's it
before we do anything else weird uh
that's it for rogue theory um
guys thanks for coming out on thank you
to leo he's the winner
yay leo thank you for jo to joven for
coming back we love you we love your
mustache
we love your theories everything um eric
as always you're the king of theories
and the king
i stan eric
who is that the king of that yes put a
crown on his head
uh guys don't forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed and stay tuned
to the youtube channel for this
and other shows uh follow us on twitter
at new rockstars i'm rene mastros you
can find me at marina masteros on
everything
bye guys thanks for having us
we
[Music]
you
[Music]